[Music]
this week we've got
eye holes vomit ceremony
and ironic break-in i have eye holes you
such a a-ho
eye-holes so this woman who's 25 years
old
that [ __ ] she claims that her phone
has baked her eyes like a microwave and
burned 500 holes in her eyes
how did she count 500 with no eyesight
because she's
a genius no just kidding no the doctor
said that she from just being on the
phone too much
yes at least it was even like 250 per
eye
the [ __ ] was she doing with the phone
dude so she said that
there was on that thing all day it's not
an iphone guarantee
oh it's an android burner it's like a
track phone or something yeah like some
some go phone yeah so they they're
saying that um
she turned her phone up to maximum
screen brightness one day so she could
see
when she was outdoors and she never
turned it down
for two years and this was
emitting 625 lumens which is over
doubling the recommended level of 300.
it didn't bother her eyes i know so
bright that you're just like
because your eyes just naturally try to
defend the [ __ ] eyeballs and they're
like ooh
like my eyes ever did that really try
staring at the sun and
okay i'll try it inside go try it go
right now
go maybe her eyes got so burned the
first time that they didn't know to
protect themselves anymore her eyes are
dumb
yeah no i mean idiot eyes
i get really sensitive to that mega
brightness too
and then every time casey shows me
something on his laptop i'm like god
damn how can you see this it's way too
bright so i'm always like lowering it
for him and trying to protect his eyes
but anyway this is the woman i forget
that things are bright too
oh that makes sense so they did report
that it's an iphone let me tell you they
did report that
we were not sure what her mobile phone
was
she's showing us at the time at the time
but then yeah at the time but she is
using an iphone currently
and she probably got a screenshot of an
iphone and just put that she switched to
an iphone after the other phone burned
her eyes
this is the android company trying to
take down
android conspiracy she was hired by
android does she have black eyes
yes because all the holes got burned
holy [ __ ] but did you know
the color this is her dog
talking about her eyes and then like all
the little holes it's probably not
that bright to her i don't trust that
guy for some reason
it's cause he's dark as hell shady what
he's in the shadow
i know he's in the shadow he looks like
an 11 year old boy in a suit
not from this thing no okay from this
angle now he looks like a casino
degenerate no he still looks like a man
to me
i think but i disagree completely so
her eyes were really red and that's what
led her to go to the doctor so this is
what her eyes look like when she first
yeah they're black look at that man it's
like [ __ ] horror movie [ __ ]
that is some horror movie yeah you can't
tell the difference between the iris and
the pupil
but that's what it looks like when you
get a little bit come in your eye that's
why i won't
we don't do facials anymore oh anymore
good for you your skin is great
we that's [ __ ] it's what happens it
stays like that the first time it
happened i was like what the [ __ ] i
[ __ ] my eyes up that ain't right you
don't like that policy i don't like i
disagree with the policy
i don't know if this is better enough
that's because your little sperms are
trying to [ __ ]
go inside the eye like it's all over i'm
pregnant my eyeball
i'm gonna do it anyway the darker your
iris yeah the less light it takes in
that's why she could handle the
highlights
does casey wear sunglasses while he's on
his laptop no and i bought him those
computers you might have too and he'll
never use
those wow we all see different yeah we
all see different colors and pictures
it does have darker eyes than i do yeah
my friend with really blue eyes she's
really like realized she can barely go
outside she's like that's jess
she needs glasses like i'm like why
trying to be cool all the time
leave her alone no but that's in the
very beginning i didn't realize
that light eyes i don't think it's
jess's light eyes i just think it's her
white-ass skin yeah dude she's wearing
scuba gear to the pool
i love you i love you i love you she
called jess's skin a reflector
it is it's a snow it's a bounce board
yeah
this is jess's arm oh my god it's
translucent dude you need sunglasses to
look at it dude
leave her alone it's because i know
she's watching this is my way to connect
i love you girl
but i learned so much about white people
i didn't know about the whole melanin
thing
what i mean i i knew melanin exists
i just didn't know that there were some
people that didn't like
redheads right yeah that totally don't
have it i didn't know that it was very
little i was like thinking well
you know yeah they'll eventually tan
right no they i didn't know that they
just
no i just didn't know that people
couldn't tan i i thought that it was
possible
that everyone yeah that's why they have
like spray tans and like the tanning no
wait the tanning pads
see i don't know this stuff i didn't
know auntie lohan's a perfect example
when she had spray tanner it just looked
[ __ ] weird it's like you're a redhead
this looks crazy
oh yeah i've never seen any tan redhead
people yeah because they can't
oh my god my mind is blown i didn't know
until i dated a redhead even canelo
right he's mexican
but he's a redhead and i've never seen
him tan it's like i've never met a
redhead who wasn't amish
i've never even met amish never one time
and then the the
light colored eyes it takes in a lot of
light like
it's super bright yeah there's some good
looking redheads that are tan
we didn't say good good looking no no no
no no no
redheads can't tip us through our own
thing
not
not saying that you guys said that there
weren't any i'm just saying like damn
there's a lot of good looking no they
said you threw in your own yeah you're
doing your own thing i did
that's what i'm saying can i see can i
see because
oh god damn well that's that's just the
picture right she's not she's not she's
not natural
she couldn't she no for sure i'm just
looking at tan see that's like
she's beautiful yeah but that looks like
contour look
that chick like you could see that she
didn't blend it enough
like look at it it's a contour and
contour contour yeah it looks like [ __ ]
nice i'm just saying she did she used to
blend it a little bit more that's all
that's all i love yeah when i was
looking at this i'm like
that article might be about badly
blended you know you know how i found
out
about um light eyes taking more light
i was in japan and i was watching uh uh
just a daytime television
and then they're like you know uh
foreigners come to
japan and they always say that our
houses are too bright
and then they had this scientist go well
that's because you know flourishing
lights in the japanese home
it's it's it's like raspberries
scientists yeah and it affects their
eyes different
he's like attached like that's because
he was like that's because the light is
in the eye there we go anyway
it's the japanese scientist's voice he's
studying very
hard so like he's smoking cigarettes and
he's studying
but yeah that's i i saw this whole thing
and then they even had an animation and
[ __ ] they had like a [ __ ] anime
white person come out and then the light
turned on and they're like oh my god
it's too [ __ ] bright and i was like
wow i didn't know that
i'm glad you learned from the
educational show that was tight i was
like damn floors and lights [ __ ] up
their eyes
no wonder when you go to restaurants
that shit's always dark as [ __ ]
i think it's also because people are on
first dates and that's like some pretty
good mood lighting
it covers up all your imperfections
because a lot of nice american
restaurants to me it feels like i'm
eating in a cave
really it's too dark i like it i like it
it's never as dark as a [ __ ]
experience we had for your birthday oh
yeah that's for sure
dude have you ever been to a bar during
the day though because like i've been
i've done that filming before
it's pretty [ __ ] gross man it is
nasty like when you have all the lights
on it looks bright as day in there
you're like holy
[ __ ] well no the bar that we went
through during the daytime they
kept it really dark still somehow
because there's no windows
yeah that's smart because then you don't
see how sticky everything looked like
yeah
everything looks so sticky man all right
next story
this buddhist master from taiwan
went viral it could be my mom she was
walking on a red carpet doing this like
how crazy would it be if it wasn't right
i was like what the [ __ ]
she was spinning for four minutes
straight
that sounds like herself a blessing
ritual and towards the end of it
four minutes she throw up there's a
surprise i'm not gonna
i i cried laughing watching this you
guys this is
i'm not gonna kill it just watch it show
you four minutes obviously it's a lot
this is
almost two minutes lesson yeah yeah
so this is already two minutes in that
she's spinning yeah yeah she's been
spinning for like
four minutes so she's grabbing a water
bottle or like holy water holy water
that's what she's doing
from the people but it's funny because
she smacks them with the water a little
bit
because she gets dizzy and she throws
the water bottle it looks like it's
going to hit people too
but this isn't the funny part this is
like just ritual oh oh
she's supposed to be spitting damn good
for her though look at her she i would
have been on the floor already at this
point
yeah 10 minutes it looks like she's
trying to start a dance party but
everybody wants to participate damn
time to shine she's doing her [ __ ] you
know like
it's it's legit oh my god poor woman
please
like she stopped in one spot what's the
world record for this [ __ ] how long was
she supposed to go
i don't know but she did spend four
minutes straight
yeah i had to fast forward but does she
even remember who she is
she's not moving anymore i know she's
still moving
all her hair fell off from moving oh no
should all the evils are coming out
oh [ __ ]
she's getting extra black well what
would you do come on
no it's just that it's this holy person
being like and that's the end of my
ritual
it's like when it's like when uh when
chris angel
does a does that [ __ ] kill where he's
like looks like he's flying and then
afterward he's like
god damn that took all my [ __ ] energy
like all breathing heavy and [ __ ] i love
that stuff this this has been going
viral so you know what's gonna happen
right
but then this just comes out of nowhere
because she just keeps spinning
yeah we know we saw yeah but like do you
think your mom would do this
yeah my mom would do [ __ ] like that
would she puke too
she'll do that on her own she'll
probably puked too like she comes over
and plays with tycho like crazy
and then like she like like she doesn't
know how to you know like moderate her
energy
so she comes over plays with them super
intense screaming
and then after she's like oh oh [ __ ] my
heart
and she goes i gotta take a nap and she
ends up like sleeping on the couch for
like two hours
because she can't drive home oh damn joe
needs his own show like ridiculousness
where he just wha he plays the video and
then he just explains
exactly what just happened i think
that'd be great
while holding like axes and [ __ ]
swords and [ __ ]
what would you call it obvious
obviousness not ridiculous
or oblivious maybe no obviousness is
good that was disgusting
it's pretty funny it's pretty funny
because that lady she's a monk right
so she's someone that's devoted herself
to the religion
vowed never to have sex ever again vowed
to never have a spouse
shaved her head has incense burned into
her scalp for
each one of her vows like a cigarette
burn
and that's the highlight of her career
yep it's spinning around and throwing
yup
that's why it's even funnier it's like
what the [ __ ] it's like someone that was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] castrate my nuts
for this cause
and then you say yeah because it's so
serious
i'm having a better time watching you
yeah that's like a priest keeping a
baptist boy he [ __ ] pukes on the baby
that's why i think god has a good sense
of humor i know oh yeah
it's so funny they only got one thing to
do
when i was in high school i went to this
girl's like uh
sixth night of hanukkah or some [ __ ]
yeah and they lit all the candles on the
menorah
and then um they they're like oh wait
don't open the door the dog's coming in
and the dog comes in
and he walks up to the coffee table
where they they lit the
menorah and his tails wagon and he puts
out all the cannons
all of them out while the grandpa was
doing it and they're just like oh
i like it i love this [ __ ] it's like
blessing [ __ ] yeah i
i was laughing so hard that i was crying
did you turn them all
back on did they turn the candles on
you're like my filipino grandma
well they had to go they had to go jump
them you light the candles okay oh my
god my brain
you switch them on i had to pull my car
around and we gave it a jump
[Laughter]
all right for our last story this little
girl
this one-year-old little girl named
little dallas
she was accidentally locked into the
vehicle
by her dad so her dad accidentally
locked her in there and so
they called cops and then that's when
cops were like
hey you know what let's get some inmates
out here
what open the car and that's what they
did so here's a video how do they have
these inmates just handy
they were out on the work work release
so they just assumed these inmates could
unlock the car
they got it they got it because the
sheriff couldn't do it that's tight
yes thank god until they uncover
them and let them [ __ ] break into a
car and then they put it back in
put them back in cuffs and take them
back to jail
happy valentine's day hey thank you guys
so much
now get your ass back in jail honey was
that stressful oh
oh okay it was like two hours
how did the baby get locked in there
they just reported that the dad
accidentally
at least it wasn't like a frying hot day
or something oh they well it is in
florida they should have broke the
[ __ ] yeah why didn't the dad just
break the glass i know
exactly that's like way too long or
couldn't they call a locksmith or
something i wouldn't even
i think i would panic so hard that i'm
not thinking of anything else and i'm
just like breaking the [ __ ] i'm
breaking something i would just find
like a brick or a rock on the ground or
something
but then you might hit your kid well
i'll choose one of the other windows or
something
i would even go to the [ __ ] front and
try to slap i would do anything that
reminds me of though
have you seen that video of all the
inmates where the jail war
or the jail security guy like um has
like a heart attack
oh yeah and they save his life and they
all like break down the door
and they get the other cops and then
they like the other cops help the guy
and they put the inmates back in the
cell
but like they're like ah no one's
hearing them and help all these guys get
like time off or something
or a treat yeah give them a treat well
and they're for non-violent crimes
so hopefully that does help they were
just all in there for
carjacking so that's why they're like
hey we got a car full of carjackers
it's too easy and then as they're doing
it they're like oh i gotta come back to
this i [ __ ] love this knife
i'm doing this
yeah they're [ __ ] addicted to that
[ __ ] damn
yeah so the mom was like yeah it was
just really funny you can't
not notice the irony here i like how
they're still wearing that [ __ ]
stripe inmates like i don't even know a
lot of jail that do that still
i know it's like for the new inmates
they put them in that and then until
they get their
uniforms then they get the orange ones
when we were watching making a murderer
whenever he'd first go to jail before oh
he would be in the striped one but then
when they got him as a
inmate that would be like he's in the
traditional it'd be beige
or beige yeah have you guys seen those
like locked up or jail type of
tv shows those are pretty awesome but in
arizona
or was it new mexico but they were all
pink oh
because pink the pepto-bismol pink it
makes
them like relax because it's like a more
feminine feminine yeah motherly color
and it's difficult for them to attack
things that are wearing pink i find
mint green to be very soothing mean like
mint green mint green
like ice cream very soothing color i
think that that should be on
it's like 1950s kitchen where yeah that
should be considered i think for
for inmates it should all be passed out
just all easter colors that's true
and it should be fuzzy like this then
it's harder to attack
so they just hug each other god imagine
they're like all these violent crimes
happening and they're all under their
yeah it's pretty cute maybe it would
happen later that's a mind [ __ ]
maybe it would happen less because when
they're about to stab the person they
feel it they go
all fool like what's this made of is
this fleece that's just pretty nice
it should be like those fleece onesies
oh yeah oh my god can we have everyone
in fleece ones
i'll pay i'll use my tax dollars for
that you'll circle that bubble in that
box again
cuddly inmates
[Music]
you